the ball will end up in the hands of Tom
Brady
the dynasty continues
Virginia
this is the minute the millions along
the world have way to kill many doubted
we'd ever see it but here it is then the
time to glory
what a few weeks stretch for Jim Nantz
the only commentator the only play by
play man the only voice to call the
Superbowl men's final four national
championship and a masters and he keeps
doing it and doing it and doing it and
what a triple header it was this year
and Jim Nantz the day after the football
schedule has been revealed kind enough
to join us here a few days after the
Masters that Tiger won right here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Jim I'm
great thank you for playing those clips
I've heard the dynasty continues I had
not heard the Virginia into the game
call because I've had it straight to
agustin had to immediately move into
masters mode and I have heard the return
to glory but the stitch all three of
them together it just flooded my mind
with memories of these 63 days that I
went through and how fortunate I have
been to be a front-row witness to some
of these remarkable minutes and moments
that mean Tom Brady winning another
Super Bowl don't Bella Jack and all that
and then that Virginia's story was so
rich and then of course the tiger won
you know it's just again just dumb luck
being in the right place at the right
time but it sure has been exciting hard
to beat well I'd ask you to rank where
the moments ranked for you Jim but I can
only imagine that's a very simple answer
but I'll just let you answer that
question
you know I got asked that question and
by a great young writer to Washington
Post a couple of days ago and I know
that picked up on a lot of places and I
said at the time that I probably can't
think of any event that I've called my
life that was bigger than that Tiger
went on Sunday now look again I count my
blessings as she does is entrusted me
with these things for so many years 34
34 masters 34 Final Fours a handful of
Super Bowls and some other things it's
kind of hard to compare sport to sport
but I think I was just talking about you
take that the texture of the story after
all when your play-by-play caller your
storyteller you're not a statistician
you're really there to get to the heart
of the story and that one just runs deep
at so many levels that again you have to
show restraint you can't go into it all
because it's a visual medium
but most of the people were aware of
Tigers life and word had gone where it
had been how is on top of the world it
seemed and then came crashing down both
physically emotionally familywize all of
that and then to see what appeared to be
a remade man behind that green on Sunday
with a in it with an intense deeply
affectionate moment with his family it
was moving and it's just kind of hard
beep at this given the the arc of that
story and worried then you know how far
he'd fallen help heroes back it's just
hard to say there's a better
storytelling event that I've ever been a
part of it and I would do well and the
crew and you're the crew that you are
face front on behalf of Jim that them to
piece together the Earl Woods hug of
tiger with tiger hugging his son Charlie
that really that that brought a tear I
mean and we we always say that brings a
tear to your eye and that that's such an
overused phrase but it really did
literally started tearing up I'm
wondering with you you know you see that
or somebody gets in your ear as you're
sitting there broadcasting they're like
hey we got this I mean walk me through
how you how that hits you well as they
did everyone I've heard from who said
the same thing that moment really struck
then it was available to all of us and
I'll back you up to the 18th fairway
Tiger contemplating how he's gonna play
a second shot knowing he needs to make
just a 5 a bogey to win Steve Milton our
director cut to a shot behind the green
that there was Tigers mom cote de she
has been out of public view for a long
time sooner and sour yeah exactly
forever she's there and I identified
Charlie in the foreground Sam his
daughter in the back and his girlfriend
Erica and as soon as I that they were in
place my mind instantly went to 97 that
we were going to see a scene that was
going to rival that moment with his dad
and I and I even just as a point of
context mentioned that Tiger got
emotional in those
six when he won a royal coiling and at
the Open Championship and it was the
first major he won after his father had
passed away two months earlier and I
thought that this could be for Tiger one
of the all-time moments in victory so it
was at that time I started to try to
think about okay how am I gonna like
sign off on this thing and the word that
kept popping in my head was glory glory
being I thought a strong one because I
thought it was his game was returning to
glory which was basically extinct two
years ago let's face it was 780th in the
world he was telling people at the
champions dinner in 2017 he probably
never play again and then of course the
fact that not that we need to know
everything but we know that his family
life took a massive hit and and all that
the scandal that he lived through knee
everything I've ever heard since that
time is how he's dedicated his life to
trying to get these kids to understand
that you know his dad made mistakes and
that's not who he is and he was
dedicating his life to those two
children to have a different point of
view of when they grow up who their
father is the father that they knew
loved them it was a dedicated loyal
father it's all I've ever heard but his
last five or six years driven to give
those kids to rewrite the story of his
life to a positive a wonderful loving
relationship but you know we don't get
nor are we supposed to everybody wants
him to be on all the time for us he's on
this planet we think to perform for us
but the reality is 98% of his life is is
behind and shielded from public view and
you know we all have lives you know
you're not just on the air all the time
you have a family and a wonderful family
life as do I
I don't walk around a little over the
blue blazer in my hand and a microphone
announcing saying hello friends I have a
life and it's a rich one and it's with
my family that it's nothing more
important and I've heard the same thing
that's what Tigers been about dedicated
dad with his kids lives and and all that
and when you saw the hug and the
intensity and the warmth of it you knew
that it was real it valid
it confirmed everything I had heard it
was a wonderful thing to see so we let
the scene play out I did use the word
glory at the return to glory because
return the glory of his wife as well as
his golf game and after that played out
for a couple of minutes I finally
inserted that I never thought I would
see a moment that could rival the hug
with his father in 1997 but I think we
just did and then Nick said it was the
greatest celebration scene of all time
nothing can ever top it and then I said
that hug with his family if you're a
parent and you didn't have a tear in
your eye you're not human and you know
you're ad-libbing through all of this
and you're trying to feel the moment
Golf has a feel sport football you can't
take three snaps off and not say
anything
basketball to run up and down the floor
it's the actions moving at a rapid pace
in golf I know that some people get lost
on this but it's it's a sport where it
takes a tremendous amount of lake living
into that vibe feeling that what that
scene in that moment in the intensity or
the lack of intensity or the emotion
whatever it is you have to kind of like
lose yourself in it that's how I've
always broadcast golf never had a note
in front of me I have enough information
from a lifetime of preparation catalog
to my head I can deal up you know dial
up dates and names and places and
historical context I feel like something
that train myself to do it's a strength
for me and then I talk from my heart and
you know there weren't a lot of words
said there at the end but I wanted them
to be impactful and yeah it was it's a
hard moment to say there's anything any
better than that
over in the golf world oh you want to
talk football here no no to say this in
86 and 86 when when Jack won I was there
I was 26 years old three and half years
removed from graduated the University of
Houston and and I couldn't believe I was
there I was mortified by the enormity of
the moment and I was on the 16th hole
that day Jack made a typical birdie and
people have said there will never be
anything that will top the 86 masters
well this might have only in this regard
because I love Jack Nicklaus that family
is like family to me now I love them and
Jack's been a great dear mentor and
friend but in when Jack
86 there were still four pairings out on
the golf course she still had seven Tom
Kyte and Greg Norman to come through and
had Dragan and Tom both not bogeyed 18
there would have been a playoff
so when Jack exited the 18th green
arm-in-arm with his son Jackie he was
caddying in for him Frank stayed with a
shot only for about three or four
seconds and then he cut quickly after
something was happening on my hole at 16
I think was a Norman putt for birdie so
we didn't get that chance we didn't get
that the incredible scene that we had
displayed there the ringing of the 18th
and thousands of people a chorus
celebrating pure joy we didn't have that
so that to me breaks the tie they're the
two best golf events I think of all time
and I give the edge here because of
again the story of the rise from the
depths and the scene at the 18th
you mean you stuck the landing obviously
on Sunday and then in in retelling the
story I can listen you talk this this
way and about golf all day Jim Jim Nantz
of CBS here in the Rich Eisen show and
before we do talk football I do want to
I guess move backwards in the montage
that started our conversation if I had
told you after you called the UMBC upset
of Virginia at that moment at that very
moment that next year Virginia would win
it all what would you have said I would
not have been surprised because I
believe in the power of the story I
believe sometimes these things again I'm
going to spin off in a crazy orbit here
go for it I told this to someone else
the other day but I really believe
sometimes these things write themselves
and there's a higher power somebody
that's influencing some of this stuff
but you if you were to google search my
name in the Richmond Times from October
15th or 16th I was interviewed by a
writer there because camp was opening
that day and for the Virginia basketball
team and I was asked out I think their
season would go and I basically said I
thought they would make a great run it
maybe won a national championship I
thought the story had a part two to it
and I mean I didn't say they're gonna
win a national championship but I said
it wouldn't surprise me to see they turn
around and flip this script and they
they take the title and that's what they
did now for
that to happen though they had to be
reminded every day every practice every
media encounter they had to be reminded
about um DC then they had to play a
Purdue team that had him beat with
seconds to go they had to make a free
throw miss a free throw tap it to the
backcourt at key hey Clark chase it down
three-quarters court and like 99% of all
players would do would take in a key
from half-court missed he had a presence
of mind look up and rightful pass to
mama de ikita and he hit a runner to
send it over time you can't win that
game that's one in a thousand they won
the game in overtime and then they've
got Auburn and Auburn had him beat of
course we know there was some
controversy at the end of some of the
calls the foul call foul guy whatever I
think it was a foul he stepped something
it's all three fairways it yes three
free-throws yep yeah I'm on my golf
lexicon now but you know what are the
odds what are the odds in the national
championship game you gotta have the UH
300 hit a three to tie it with fall
seconds Montana last-second shot at the
end of regulation to go win it in
overtime I mean the odds are just
they're massive
I do feel badly in a way then maybe it's
just because I'm in this bubble having
been courtside for all these events but
it had the shortest shelf life of a
majestic story as anything I've ever
seen along comes Tiger the story was
just it was a beautiful pristine story a
tribute to a testament I should say to
character and like facing adversity and
challenges and to climb that mountain
you're gonna keep getting kicked and
tested can you do it can you can you
somehow figure a way to get out of this
moment where the odds are stacked
against you and you do it and you do it
again and you do it again and you've
been reminded about it for 350 days and
yet you come back and repeatedly do it
it's a it's a it's a it this story there
is so deep it's so big and I know it's
lost a little bit today we're just ten
days after it because the tiger thing
kind of blew it out of the water but I
am lost in admiration for Tony Bennett
and the program he runs and the kids
that are on that floor and what they did
to come back and win a championship on
the heels of the most embarrassing loss
of the history of the tournament I feel
like this is an exit interview Jim Nantz
for the great sports moment so far of
2013 so let's turn to the schedule let's
spin it a little bit forward here that
came out last night which games did you
see that are on the CBS docket that you
said I can't wait to saddle up with Tony
Romo and and call well if you put it
that way just to sit down with Tony and
call the game just about say every
single one other systems matter the game
we have a Paul Reid is that the best
time but I loved our schedule and it's
hard thing to do to keep everybody happy
as you know right and and and look our
schedules going to as always have eight
pre-assigned that's best scenarios
national doubleheaders there's some
flexibility obviously along the way in
if there's week 17 we and Fox both get a
doubleheader so you get nine total so
you really want to see what did they
drop in your lap for those four 25 and
those four twenty fives included Dallas
at the Jets early in the season lay
beyond bells like week five or six
Dallas of course is always a huge draw
that's a cross flex game but that
doesn't normally belong in our package
but this is some of the new programming
they've done the league has done in the
last three or four years that's a good
one Kansas City at New England in
December that's great is I believe it's
December 8th it's a monster game I think
that's that at least going in of course
repeated that epic AFC Championship game
that's about as good as it gets we got
New England at Philadelphia rematch of
Super Bowl 50 - not bad I mean there's
just a whole list of I think really high
quality 425 games and I'm excited about
that I I can't wait to get it started
I'm I'm taking a little deep breath
because yes
the last ball the first hundred days of
the year including that AFC Championship
game kind of gets lost in this mix of
thoughts right of games I've had a
chance to cover but it's been a
whirlwind and and I'm back on the air
I'm and dopa Head Island South Carolina
you've got a pure event this weekend and
probably the best thing for me is to
decompress by being on the air
with an event that's not at the Masters
scale but it's important to you know
whoever's playing in it and the golf
audiences is behind it and then I'm
gonna go underground for a while and and
just be with my family they're here with
me
nip which certainly is a blessing and
having them running around and making me
feel whole again and being back in my
most important role as a dad but yeah
the football season will be here before
we know it I love our schedule and I
love being with Tony and Jim Rick off
and our whole team it's awesome hi Carl
and Tracy Wolfson it's awesome yep you
got Ravens Steelers Browns Patriots
which is going to be of note towards the
end I don't wanna give away state
secrets but you know and I'm not a
programmer so it's it there is of course
the opponent's schedule that comes out
the minute the regular season ends yep
you know the opponent's as you know
right but for some reason it's more
interesting finding out where the games
are position on the calendar than who
the opponents are you know that doesn't
matter fans here at the other week 17
about the opponent schedule the big the
big reveal is your show last night but
we do several of us are asked and I have
a very minor role in this virtually
negligible qualified people like Dan
Weinberg in our place to figure this out
but I really wanted Cleveland New
England
I want to Cleveland New England and I
think that there's probably four or five
games that we go to the league and say
we'd really like to keep these we're not
going to get all five hmm but I think we
probably got four out of the five and my
big thing even before the Beckham trade
was Cleveland his team on the rise and
Baker Mayfield against Tom Brady be a
lot of energy in that building and I
really want to see us get that game that
was the one thing I pushed for I knew
that they were all over Kansas City no
way near anyone at Philadelphia and all
that kind of thing but I was thrilled to
see that's a week eight double-header
of course now beckham's on you know on
the scene and it's interesting I thought
the league showed the Browns a lot of
lovely yep
with that schedule I mean they they got
four prime time games
okay we can clicking jockey on this all
we want and those are huge but the four
twenty fives are huge the four twenty
five actually does a bigger national
rating that the prime time games does as
you know this too it's one of the little
kind of on Phonics on unexplored or
unappreciated numbers is the Fox and CBS
for 25 games actually end up at the end
of the season have two biggest rating of
any time block and they've got I believe
three Cleveland games in the four twenty
five window two of them are definitely
going to be the national game that one
at New England and the one on
Thanksgiving Sunday at s Berg right
there's a game on week nine were
Cleveland's at Denver and at the same
4:25 window is Green Bay at the Chargers
so there's a hedge there it could go
either way
Green Bay is such a national team I
would say right now that's Green Bay the
Chargers probably going in is the
favorite to be the big national game
because Denver's a little bit of a
wild-card let's face it and you know we
got to see how Cleveland's gonna react
to it I think they'll react well but I
would say Cleveland Pittsburgh and
Cleveland New England those are now with
the four prime times those are six
massive exposures for that franchise
they are and and Jim thanks for the call
really appreciate it it's just great to
hear you're happy we had Joe Buck on
last night on the network he's happy but
nobody's happier than you know this than
Al Michaels having four Los Angeles
games nobody's happier than I was
watching and after I touched you last
night and and and has had some fun with
you during her while you're on the air I
texted Al and I said I'm about to watch
you come on and I was writing in the
text you know you're interviewing yeah I
love Alan like it had such a wonderful
friend and someone that is represents
the best who cares about us and I then I
heard you mentioned before it's in LA I
know I've heard him lament for years he
never gets any breakfast he wrote me
right back I think you never know you
get flexed out of these games I know
that's right
you can't bready you never know he's got
25% of this year he's driving to work
well Jim to bring it over
right to bring it on full circle you
mentioned about being a dad being I know
you put the pause button on being a dad
to call in so head off to your family I
really appreciate the time Jim well I'd
be really rich right back and really did
there's only one Jim Nantz of CBS right
here in the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app